what is going on or reject nation it's
Greg Alva here it's John Humphrey over
here so we're gonna watch from one of my
favorite YouTube channels ever what
culture 10 movie fan theories that
creators completely rejected real
rejected but before we go into our
reaction and discussion on these
theories we wanted to give a shout out
to today's awesome video sponsor Full
Sail University now chances are if you
found your way onto this channel prior
you've probably heard us talk about Full
Sail before because there are good
friends of ours and if you're new to
this channel you're probably interested
in filmmaking in some capacity but maybe
you don't even know where to begin or
what area of film you would want to work
in that's where a full sale can help
Full Sail University offers a variety of
degrees both on campus and online that
can show you the ins and outs of
filmmaking from pre-production to post
full sales programs give you the chance
to explore the different roles involved
in the filmmaking process and allow you
access to professional equipment so you
can figure out whether you're more of an
editor a director or a camera operator
or a cetera full se also features an
online digital cinematography degree if
you're looking to learn the basics and
essentials with a modern digital spin
and Full Sail grads have gone on to work
on countless films at Hollywood
productions such as Avengers age of
Ultron Jurassic world frozen and a whole
bunch more so if you're looking to
develop your skills as a filmmaker and
tap into the business head on over to
Full Sail edu slash YouTube to learn
more about their programs and how to get
started well thanks full sail for
sponsoring this video you guys are great
peeps ten movie fan theories here
[Music]
there's nothing movie fans love more
than a healthy dose of speculation with
fan theories being the most creative
form there's speculation takes if you so
charge just about anything and it's
generally quite fun to read over
whatever crazy intricate stuff people
are able to come up with now of course
rarely is this stuff true and over the
years this has been pointed out by
people behind the film's inquest just
awful event from our culture there are
10 movie fan theories the creators
completely rejected number 10 tangled
and frozen under started frozen Anna and
Elsa's parents are shown being killed in
a boat crash but their destination is
never mentioned it was then theorized by
many that the parents were travelling to
the wedding of Rapunzel and Flynn writer
the main characters from tangled but a
violent storm took her lives before they
met that's into the tangled frozen
connection fire when Rapunzel and Flynn
were spotted at the end of frozen it's
not true though according to Mandy Moore
who voiced Rapunzel entangled and its
subsequent TV series she said there is
no connection as far as I know but is
not connected mouse key the big lebowski
lot of the most memorable part due to
its varied ensemble of interesting
characters but are they all real that's
right
this theory posits that Donnie isn't
real and is instead of figment of
Walters imagination the dude doesn't
interact with Donnie much throughout the
movie which led some viewers to believe
that Walton was just making him up when
asked about ridiculous to post the
movies directors the Coen brothers hit
back by pointing out the dude actually
does interact with Donnie saying doesn't
the dude get covered by Donnie's ashes
at the end of the movie he does you're
right number eight one of the new
characters debuting be Benicio Del
Toro's DJ has been shrouded in secrecy
since he was first revealed so as you'd
expect fans haven't wasted any time in
attempting to piece together his true
identity just let it lie once it guessed
that del Toro was playing ezra bridger
and that he'd also be Ray's father but
then along came the last Jedi director
Rian Johnson who quickly
spoiled the thought Johnson was being
interviewed by good
Peregrin when asked about the DJ ezra
theory he quickly put it to bed he's his
own person said the director DJ is his
own person
number seven Greece for quite some time
in stones Greece from a job you'll feel
good musical into a morbid depressing
character study yay the flying car at
the end of the film has always been a
point of discussion but some fans think
that it's more than just a quirky design
choice and is in fact meant to represent
lead characters sadly jetting off to
heaven during the summer night song
Danny and Sandy describe how they first
met with Danny singing I say too like
she nearly drowned not gonna sing that
don't make me sing that the theory goes
that sandy actually did drown and the
whole movie is a fantasy brought on by
the lack of oxygen her brain is
suffering Jesus thankfully this theory
was flat-out annoyed by the writer of
the original musical good suit in a
trailer for Batman V Superman that
originally sparked this idea into
existence when the first images of Jared
Leto's Joker service online completely
no David Ayer the phones are perfectly
aligned with the bullet holes in the
Apple mentioned suit the internet was
convinced that the DCE use Joker was
none of them than Jason taught here as
good as this theory was it was quashed
in an instant by Suicide Squad director
David Ayer the literally points of the
camera and says it ain't the case he's
not today well number 5 Jurassic world
Jurassic world
I've heard this one that he's the kid he
attributed yeah nostalgia the Raptors
the t-rex those Park gave the iconic
score they were all present and correct
and if this bang theory has this wave of
nostalgia would have been stretched even
further
Owen Grady Chris Pratt was supposedly a
brand-new character created for Jurassic
world but many fans speculated that
would actually see him in the very first
movie the kid who Alan Grier arises with
a raptor claw near the beginning of
Jurassic Park 1 until Chris Pratt
himself came along and devoted his I do
officially say as the Bastian of Owens
backstory but not the creator of the
character that's not true
number 4 Star Wars The Force awakens one
of the most intriguing new aspects of
star - the force awakens was the
introduction
supreme leader snoke or more
specifically finding out whether he
harbored a secret identity that topic
has been one of the biggest online
discussions in recent years popular
proposals floating around is that Snoke
is Darth Plagueis the former master of
dark Sidious now rejected at least be
rejected by the guy in charge of keeping
Star Wars Canon in check right Pablo
Hidalgo said the following on Twitter
I said Sidious killed Plagueis he killed
him killed
as in took kill like there was killing
number three Harry Potter the theories
have been rolling in long after the film
came out among the Draco is a werewolf
it was all a dream and Ron is a
time-traveling Dumbledore conspiracists
there are a select few a to believe that
Dumbledore created of all crooks and
that all crooks was false the Phoenix
the theory states that Dumbledore
accidentally killed his sister Ariana
while fighting and Gellert Grindelwald
and Aberforth Dumbledore which gave him
the ability to imbue force with a part
of his salt
JK Rowling herself took to Twitter
saying the idea anybody believes this is
strangely upsetting to me too
Mad Max fury road 2015's Mad Max fury
road was the fourth installment in a Mad
Max franchise was caught somewhere
between sequel and full-blown reboot but
because it wasn't clear whether or not
this was actually a sequel fans
questioned whether or not the character
portrayed by Tom Hardy was even Mad Max
at all he was supposed to be Mad Max and
his character is referred to as Max at
the credit but many speculated that
Hardy's renditions of Max may not be the
same character instead Hardy's Max was
widely believed to be a grownup version
of the character known as federal kid
who we last saw in Mad Max actually that
would recall that's great no
unfortunately but that's a great - it
turns out the narrator is the feral kid
as an old man and he says he max only
lives now in my memories I think that's
a reasonable interpretation not in my
mind that any of that makes sense it's a
weird quote isn't it but it basically he
says no number one toy story toy story
is one of the greatest animated films
ever made in its popularity is
created more and more questions about
the whereabouts of Andy's death
fortunately this mystery story was told
earlier this year by Mike Mozart a toy
consultant who worked on the original
Toy Story he sat down with super Carlin
brothers for a chat revealing that
Andy's father was awesome named Andy and
Andy senior was the original owner of
the Woody doll there's a whole raft of
tragic backstory involving diseases and
such which makes it all the weird of it
it's a load of bollocks
complete and utter fake news everyone go
back to your homes nothing to see here
folks hashtag I was there said Toy Story
writer Andrew Stanton that's just
embarrassing like isn't it why would you
and that song is to make sure you
subscribe to the world coaching YouTube
channel for more lists like to visit
news thanks for watching
I thought Snoke was an e circus in real
life yeah no I think the tangled in
frozen what could still be applicable
though the animations similar enough
Mandy Moore is just the voice of one of
the characters well yes it's not like
they've never hidden you know
referential Easter eggs and the
backgrounds of these things yeah tangled
and frozen they look so similar in its
animation style one of the creators have
debunked it you know this is Mandy Moore
as the just the voice actor so she's
like not that I know of oh I don't think
they're connected you know maybe they
don't have some big elaborate plan but
Disney's I wouldn't be surprised dizzy
was like yeah actually they were no
one's not mind-blowing to me either way
if Tarantino's Vega brothers can exist
in the pulp fiction universe for
something the Big Lebowski not believing
Donnie is real that's just a stupid
theory to me this is reading way too
much into it for me I think it's pretty
amusing but yeah I don't buy that theory
as being an actual thing I would just
think it's stupid I got that's actually
my first time hearing it but when I
heard I'm like what he clearly interacts
with Donnie he doesn't say a lot to him
but he look like there's like looking
directly at him yeah yeah yeah yeah
reacting to him and he does get the
ashes on into yeah yeah I think the
ashes is the biggest undoing
of that I mean unless you go so far as
to say like oh it could be anything
maybe he's crazy and he just he just
found a bunch of ash in some world and
also with Benicio del Toro with Rian
Johnson is just saying he's his own
person
DJ is his own person this isn't
necessarily debunk it you could be
clever enough with your words where
you're not lying but you're also
concealing yeah I'm sure like my brain
is flip-flopping on that one because
he's not just saying no it's not true
like the worst DJ is his own person are
very deliberately chosen it seems like
however the other half of my brain is
like no that seems to mean what it means
this guy is his own character and he's
not other characters I don't find that
one particularly like oh my goodness
thank opiez Ray's father
we learned that Ray as Mexican how cool
would that be sir British dude flip this
Star Wars world upside down Steven Yeun
to be there as kylo ren's new
replacement oh man kylo - yeah kylo Glen
Oh Greece I've actually heard that
Theory before loosen ation cuz the lack
of oxygen in her brain
I find how do people read so much into
something like this I I find a theories
like that incredibly amusing I don't
ever think that they're really that true
but I'm like yeah I suppose if you want
to take it down that road and then and
surmise that this is just a fantasy
sandy is having as she drowns to death
ah do you have at it okay saying to me
is the same theory to me man it is I
just think it's really ridiculous
it makes the movie that much more
weirdly charming to me to think of it
that way I don't think it's actually I
would love to create something that
people speculate on and multiple
theories about and just walk out and go
it's all true all of it but these
conflict with this yeah it's all truth
life can flick life completely things
The Suicide Squad one was actually
pretty disappointing to me because I
actually really liked that theory that
Jason Todd is really the Joker it just
made sense to me when I heard that
theory with a tease and bbs then you're
getting the Joker and the next one and
then the bullet holes and the tattoos it
all seemed in alignment and I thought
to be a cool thing they do with the DCE
you yeah sort of a new story for their
yeah version of the Joker and then
hearing David Ayer spearhead the leader
of the DC Universe completely debunking
that because he has all the answers they
will give him all the answers so we know
that's not true super first in my bubble
read of an interesting the Jurassic Park
one mm-hmm that's another one where I'm
like hey that might be true actually he
didn't create the character but he just
played the character for all we know
maybe it's just an IMDB search away of
going and going what's this kid's name
yeah in Jurassic Park and then looking
if it matches up with the Jurassic world
one see I thought the theory was that he
was Tim oh that would meant stupid
theory yeah well he's harder as well if
he's just this random kid I'm like oh
sure oh no I sound like a side-by-side
image comparison when he's like holding
the claw I'm like at one point chris
pratt's doing that and then the kids
talking about the Raptors and Chris
Pratt has an obsession with the Raptors
this makes more sense yes I thought it
would have been kind of a cool theory
that are cool actually
it's not true to him but I guess it
still could be plausible
everybody knows emperor Snoke is mace
windu everyone knows know why people
can't grab on why can't people just
grasp that simple fact yeah that Andy
Serkis is doing a Samuel Jackson
impersonation Harry Potter one just
sounds ridiculous to me that just sounds
like so much mumbo-jumbo
Dumbledore Horcrux things I just like
that the JK Rowling was disturbed by
this yeah this is upsetting to me that
someone will believe this you gotta be
in some pretty dark stuff to make a
Horcrux right and like that's not
Dumbledore that's not dumb BD why is his
name dumb then haha yeah boys you
gentlemen have a good point but it's a
good quip still Mad Max is is similar
it's similar to the Jurassic Park one I
felt like this sort of visit I thought
that one makes sense
I even like how George America George
Miller that George Miller was like hey
cool idea
yeah so I feel like you know you're
allowed to have your cake a little
because he has the grunts and everything
that is resemblance of the little boy in
in the road warrior and I haven't heard
that theory actually and he could have
just taken you know he met max so maybe
he just took the name as he grew up yeah
but there's that ending narration of the
road warrior that kind of debunks it a
little bit yeah yeah you know III do
enjoy that as well and even George wish
I went with that wouldn't have to worry
about having to replace Mel Gibson
necessarily yeah the the the
aforementioned rejections in the title
of this video you know that's the the
softest rejection I think he had a
respectful like appreciation for that
theory when I got imagine that's that's
sort of a cool thing about being a
creative type and having somebody come
to you and be like hey I found this this
other life inside of your story even to
be like that's not what I intended it's
so cool that you know it's plausible
yeah I have a theory
what's that that Andy's dad is is really
the kid from child's play and this
situation just follows them yeah a toy
story's a child's play to remake I think
that's the case it's just a friendlier
child's play to similar please why would
you do child's play where it's about a
boy having a doll that comes to life
with a kid named Andy and then toy
stores about a kid named Andy whose toys
are really alive it's too similar my
theory is it's like a kids movie remake
of child's play see that's all she
Chucky up here I love to see Chucky
appear now Toy Story is that much more
disturbing because now you have to think
how many people knew voodoo well enough
to transport their souls into this
child's toys why does this child have
like a community of you know they don't
have to be felons with Charles Lee ray
is not a savory cat how many criminals
are living in Andy's bedroom John and
nailed it
what okay Andy's dad died and his body
was transported inside of the Woody doll
but along the process he lost his memory
and can't remember that he really is the
father of Andy and that's why he's so
attached to Auntie BAM my name is Greg
Allen ladies and gentlemen have a good
night
you can subscribe to the Rio rejects
click that
a notification value get notified every
time or some times or any time reviewer
video is out and don't forget if you're
interested in filmmaking go check out
Full Sail please good folks over there
the greg alba is on twitter instagram
I'm dad John Humphrey on Twitter and
Instagram you can find us at the real
rejects on Twitter at real rejects on
Instagram on Facebook wherever books are
sold jump on it jump out of it do the
Hokey Pokey and you turn yourself around
and that's what it's that's what it's
all about
John week part two all right